de la réalité vécue par beaucoup de gens
et que cette réalité s'étend au monde du travail.
Que ce soit dans la technologie, les finances, le sport ou le tertiaire,
nous semblons entendre chaque jour une nouvelle histoire d'abus de pouvoir
ou d'un comportement ouvertement inopportun sur le lieu de travail.
Les gens sont en colère.
Ils vont sur Twitter et les réseaux sociaux
pour exprimer la nécessité de changement.
Mais il est temps d'aller au-delà du hashtag.
Il est temps de signaler le harcèlement et la discrimination
à ceux qui peuvent régler cela.
Il est temps de parler de harcèlement
de façon plus inclusive :
pas seulement de harcèlement sexuel,
mais d'encourager les gens à signaler
le harcèlement et la discrimination basés sur d'autres caractéristiques
telles que l'âge, un handicap ou l'ethnie.
Il n'y a qu'ensemble que nous pouvons régler
les causes sous-jacentes et les conséquences du harcèlement.
La plupart d'entre nous,
à un moment de notre vie,
nous serons victimes de harcèlement ou de discrimination au travail.
La recherche montre que les femmes, les personnes de couleur
et les gens s'identifiant comme LGBTQI ont des risques d'être visés
et pour certains, cela est omniprésent et permanent dans leur réalité.
Pour la plupart de ces gens --
98% d'après certaines études --
la plupart de ces gens n'en parleront jamais à leur employeur.
Trop souvent, le harcèlement et la discrimination
sont une expérience isolante et solitaire,
mais nous devons aider les gens à dévoiler leur souffrance.
Nous devons autonomiser les gens afin qu'ils aient une voix.
La première question raisonnable que tout le monde pose
après avoir été harcelé est : « Que faire maintenant ? »
C'est ici que je veux vous aider.
Passer les barrières pour signaler peut être vertigineusement complexe.
Comment s'exprimer dans une société
qui, trop souvent, discrédite ou minimise notre vécu ?
qui sera probablement punitive avec nous ?
Comment gérer la contrainte du silence qui nous entoure ?
Pour ne rien arranger,
souvent nos souvenirs sont la seule preuve que nous avons de ce qu'il s'est passé.
Et c'est là que j'entre en jeu.
Je suis spécialiste de la mémoire
et de comment nous nous souvenons des événements émotionnels importants.
Je me suis particulièrement concentrée sur comment l'interrogation de la mémoire
peut sévèrement affecter la qualité probante des rapports produits.
Un mauvais interrogatoire peut vous mener à oublier ou vous tromper sur des détails
alors qu'un bon interrogatoire
peut pour toujours changer le cours de votre vie.
Après avoir examiné des rapports de laboratoire et travaillé,
étudié cette question dans un contexte judiciaire et de recherche,
j'ai disséqué les différentes choses pouvant mal se passer avec vos souvenirs
et pouvant menacer votre affaire.
Je porte maintenant mon attention sur comment aider les gens
à consigner et signaler le harcèlement et la discrimination au travail.
J'ai appris trois choses de ma recherche à ce sujet
que vous pouvez appliquer immédiatement
si vous avez été harcelé ou discriminé au travail.
Je veux vous aider à transformer vos souvenirs en preuves --
preuves auxquelles un sceptique de la mémoire
ne trouvera rien à redire.
Tout d'abord, James Comey avait raison.
L'ancien directeur du FBI s'asseyait dans sa voiture,
s'enfermait après les réunions avec le Président
et écrivait absolument tout ce dont il se rappelait de ce qu'il s'était passé.
Les transcriptions, aujourd'hui célèbres, se sont avérées utiles plus tard.
Soyez comme Comey.
Inutile de vous enfermer dans votre voiture pour faire cela
mais immédiatement après un événement,
je veux que vous consigniez directement ce qu'il s'est passé.
Faites-le avant d'en parler à qui que ce soit.
Car dès que vous partagez votre histoire
avec des amis, de la famille, des collègues, un thérapeute,
vous pouvez déformer ou changer votre souvenir de l'événement.
Une preuve instantanée et intacte vaut de l'or.
Deux : enregistrez la preuve.
Vous pouvez rédiger une note manuscrite,
mais comment prouver quand vous l'avez écrite ?
Au lieu de cela, sortez votre ordinateur ou téléphone
et rédigez une note horodatée,
où vous pouvez prouver qu'elle a été consignée à ce moment-là.
Une preuve instantanée et horodatée, c'est mieux.
Pour finir, assurez-vous que ce que vous écrivez est pertinent.
Trop souvent, les gens sortent des messages Facebook,
une preuve horodatée,
mais pas particulièrement pertinente,
pas particulièrement utile.
Il est facile d'écrire
une description émotionnelle, non structurée de l'événement --
de façon compréhensible car c'est une expérience émotionnelle --
mais ce ne sont pas forcément les détails qui importeront plus tard
pour une enquête.
Écrivez cette liste.
Je veux que vous gardiez une trace de cela et remplissiez simplement les trous.
Tout d'abord, que s'est-il passé ?
Avec autant de détails que possible,
décrivez la situation
et faites-le le jour même si cela est possible.
Deuxièmement, qui était là ?
Y avait-il des témoins ?
Cela peut être crucial plus tard.
Quel jour et à quelle heure cela s'est-il passé ?
Dans quel lieu ? Où cela s'est-il passé ?
A qui en avez-vous parlé après l'événement ?
Comment vous êtes-vous senti pendant et après ?
Y a-t-il d'autres preuves telles que des messages, photos ou mails
pouvant conférer plus de crédibilité à ce que vous avancez.
Tous ces détails sont incroyablement faciles à consigner sur le moment
mais incroyablement faciles à oublier plus tard.
D'après la recherche, les êtres humains surestiment souvent leur capacité
à se souvenir de détails émotionnels importants par la suite.
Considérez que vous allez oublier.
Considérez que vous devez les écrire.
Ces trois conseils sont un bon début,
mais ne permettent pas de surmonter
nombre des autres obstacles au signalement.
D'après la commission pour l'égalité et les droits de l'Homme,
qui a publié un rapport en 2018,
il y a une recommandation clé pour surmonter certaines des peurs
souvent associées au signalement de tels incidents à votre employeur.
Un conseil qu'ils ont donné ?
Avoir un outil en ligne de signalement anonyme.
Il n'y a que cela, disent-ils,
qui puisse vraiment vaincre nombre des peurs associées au signalement.
Dans cette optique,
ayant connaissance de ce qui arrivait tout autour de moi
et appliquant la science de la mémoire,
la science que je pratiquais depuis de nombreuses années,
j'ai discuté avec nombre de personnes
et, ensemble, nous avons créé TalkToSpot.com.
Spot est un outil de signalement anonyme en ligne
aidant à consigner et signaler
le harcèlement et la discrimination au travail.
Il vous permet de le faire anonymement,
gratuitement
et se base entièrement sur des preuves.
Pas besoin de parler à quelqu'un,
pas de crainte d'être jugé,
et vous pouvez le faire n'importe quand et n'importe où.
Vous pouvez suivre un interrogatoire s'appuyant sur les preuves.
Cela s'appelle un entretien cognitif.
C'est la technique que la police utilise quand elle fait son travail correctement.
Dans le meilleur des cas,
les gens interrogés sur des événements émotionnels importants
sont interrogés conformément à l'entretien cognitif.
Il vous fait passer en revue toutes les informations pertinentes
afin qu'à la fin, après avoir parlé au bot --
qui est un système de discussion automatique --
après avoir parlé au bot,
cela génère un rapport PDF horodaté et signé de façon sûre
que vous pouvez préserver comme preuve si vous voulez le partager plus tard
ou que vous pouvez soumettre immédiatement à votre employeur.
Conformément aux recommandations,
vous pouvez le soumettre à votre employeur de façon anonyme.
Mais l'utilité d'un outil de signalement dépend de l'auditoire.
Si votre employeur est déterminé à faire changer les choses,
nous avons décidé de lui offrir l'outil pour répondre.
Si les organisations travaillent avec nous
et sont vraiment engagées à agir
contre le harcèlement et la discrimination,
elles peuvent vous répondre,
même si vous avez choisi de rester anonyme.
Il est important que vous puissiez travailler avec votre employeur
pour vous attaquer à ce problème.
Nous pensons que tout le monde gagne
quand nous faisons la lumière sur ce sombre problème.
Que cela vous arrive à vous ou à une connaissance,
consigner et signaler l'événement
peut vraiment améliorer notre façon de parler de ces problèmes.
Si vous êtes une organisation,
c'est un appel à offrir à vos employés un accès
à des mécanismes de signalement meilleurs et plus efficaces.
Nous savons que les méthodes actuelles
utilisées dans la plupart des organisations
ne sont pas efficaces.
Il est temps de changer cela si vous êtes attaché à l'inclusion et la diversité.
Il est temps que nous célébrions notre diversité.
Il est temps que nous donnions la parole
à ceux à qui, pendant trop longtemps, nous avons refusé de la donner.
Il est temps que nous célébrions ceux qui se manifestent,
même s'ils pensent devoir rester anonymes --
rester masqués pour ce faire.
Il est temps d'avoir une révolution du signalement.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)